what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time while ostrich trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right I am here with the
beautiful intelligent plenty of Mara
Nova she's got on her
unauthorized advertisement year I don't
know if we could show it there there's
the profile gear she's got it on she's
rocking it don't forget get money get
paid
black Phi is now sponsoring lunch money
they got three products you can buy
itself cryptocurrency you can deposit
crypto and get a u.s. dollar loan or my
favorite product I'm an investor and a
user a heavy user is to deposit either
cash or crypto and you can earn up to
eight point six percent eight point six
percent APY is unheard of interest rate
go check them out block by comm but use
the link in the description of the video
so that we get credit so they think
we're cool they know you guys are cool
speaking of not cool
what's going on with unemployment huh
people just can't get their lunch money
right so one in four American workers
have filed for unemployment benefits
during the pandemic as of today another
2.1 million people filed initial jobless
claims last week 2.1 million last week
that brings a total to more than 40
million Americans in the last
two-and-a-half months
forty million people have lost their
jobs in less than 90 days unfathomable I
mean just literally never happened
before in the history of the United
States I read an article that said I
didn't read the Mordecai just for the
headline which is the problem with most
Americans read the whole article but
anyway it said it said the millennial
generation is one of the unluckiest
generations in history
why look why is it unlucky well because
you've been through so many things right
there was the recession 9/11 what else
is there this there's something else
yeah I feel like there's always bad [ __ ]
going on in the world
so the whole thing here is I actually
don't think it's one in four think it's
more the last time I checked the
American workforce is only about a
hundred and fifty five million people
right and so if 40 million it's almost
one out of three Americans is it it's
more than 40 million Americans right so
it's it's just devastating and I think
part of this is there's a lot of things
at work here so obviously one the virus
has led to people losing their jobs to
is unemployment got beefed up so there's
literally people who are saying hey fire
me cuz I'll make more an unemployment
then I would hear my job which probably
says more about the fact that we don't
pay people enough money to begin with
and now that we're starting to reopen
the economy we're gonna get the we're
gonna get the hard truth how many of
those jobs are still available how many
of those jobs are coming back my guess
is that we're gonna see 20 percent of
small businesses not come back and if
that happens they're responsible for 50
percent of jobs in America that would be
a 10 percent loss of job opportunities
in the United States and so hopefully
this reverses quickly but uh it's just
super sad we're still seeing you know
millions literally 2.1 million people
last week filed for first-time
unemployment claims and I don't think
it's gonna stop I think we're still
gonna see more than a million people a
week all the way through the end of June
and even if the economy reopens we just
gotta hurry up and do it and do it
safely but we got to do it hungry
you agree nice starting off Thursday
with an agree wait I told him about this
morning sure okay so this morning I
don't know what you're excited about
this this isn't very exciting this is
actually horrifying it's a little crazy
but I'm gonna tell you anyway because
we're friends now
so um I he woke me up this morning
well I woke up I went and did some work
came back she was still sleeping and I
woke her up at the crack of dawn Sun
comes up it's like it's a natural alarm
clock get your ass out of bed let's go I
don't see no Sun at seven o'clock in the
morning
cooking yourself breakfast or something
cuz I don't need breakfast me I don't
eat breakfast but I would enjoy it okay
so people who've seen that YouTube video
and those called whistle tips go look on
YouTube so anyway so this morning he
wakes me up and in my dream state I wake
up I see him and I'm like oh okay
you're waking me up cool Thanks and then
I go back to sleep because no you were
arguing with me in your dream I woke you
up I was nice to you and then you told
me oh by the way when I went back to
sleep I went back to arguing with you
cuz I had to let dream Anthony know
exactly how I felt but just so you're
clear reality is on nice well in your
dreams on me okay let's go to social
media another place where there's fake
things going this is what I deal with on
a daily basis literally she's mad at me
because something that happened in
answering what's going on social social
media Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
questions Twitter's decision to
fact-check to tweets from President
Donald Trump saying private companies
shouldn't serve as an arbiter of truth
what do you think I I don't think the
Twitter and Facebook are equipped to be
making decisions like that reporters are
barely equipped decisions like that so I
don't know they should just either be
platforms and be super clear and what
kind of speech is allowed what's not or
but but we live in this world of like
nothing is real anymore like there's so
much fake or everything's fake there's
two points you don't know the first they
shouldn't be arbiters of truth because
there is no truth that's what people
don't realize there is no black and
white this is true this is not true
you give me any set of facts and I will
tell you two truths that are
contradictory to each other yeah there
is no truth no there's not that name one
gravity gravity is a fact
except for let me tell you all of the
nuanced cases and edge cases where it's
not true no yeah
true if I go into an antigravity tank
there's no gravity oh my god again
though when you get into the nuances
it's impossible for them to police every
single nuance and edge case right so
again it then comes down to then there's
a Philip inion opinion and then if we
get into if I say that gravity's not
real and they say I'm lying well
actually every scientific breakthrough
for the most part has started with
somebody setting up a thesis or a
hypothesis that was previously thought
to be false okay right and so let's say
that I am saying if Twitter was around
I'm saying if they censor people and
they say things aren't true it will
actually drastically slow down
innovation when it comes to Sciences for
example right so right now let's take
the bar is a super extreme example with
the virus there's probably 15 different
possibilities of where it came from how
it spread all this stuff some of them
are incredibly politically charged and
some of them are straight down the
fairway no one thinks that they're
controversial we don't know what the
truth is but if you're not allowed to
explore every single idea then you
actually never will find the truth but
what about people who are saying things
that all right are a hypothesis but
they're stating it as fact again now you
get into intention that's really what
they're trying to arbitrate on here it's
not truth what they're trying to
arbitrate is actually intention
maliciousness the problem is you can't
do that because there's too much context
to it so then they I don't think that
they should be doing any of this if you
walk in the in the grocery store you
know how they have the magazine's right
and Pete and you walk by them and
they're like oh here's pictures of this
woman pregnant or look at this guy or
whatever the tabloid stuff that's most
that's fake news but no one's running
around saying that uh you know thank
news in the tabloids is changing society
or even terian but the point being that
everyone just wants to lash out at the
tech companies but at the end of the day
fake news is not new fake news has been
around forever they've been publishing
fake news and all yellow journalism so
my point is one they shouldn't be the
arbitrator truth
but if reporters because journalists
love this is like the journalism 101
let's yell and scream at the tech
companies because there's such bad
people these billionaires are changing
the world and only you know curving it
towards what their ideology if you want
to be the arbitrator of truth the same
standards you want apply to politicians
should be applied to the media companies
and you know interesting nuance here is
that news organizations used to have so
many fact checkers fact checkers
everywhere every single word in fact was
checked and verified and etc now it's
like all these budgets are slashed they
don't even some of them may not even
have a lot of fact checkers if you know
they have it well so here's a super
complex issue right if you're gonna
fact-check the news literally there will
be mainstream media The Washington Post
the New York Times all across the
ideological spectrum they publish things
that are inaccurate all the time many
times they will either attract or they
will correct they'll do all that kind of
stuff but if all of a sudden Twitter
started to correct the New York Times
and Washington Post imagine that world
imagine how much they will be is Twitter
only fact-checking trump or as twitter
fact-checking
everyone their whole thing right now is
they are going to start to implement
fact-checking but it's not so much
fact-checking as in like is this true is
this not their point was if you say
something as a politician that would do
voter suppression then we want to
basically tell people here's here's a
different set of information and then
you make your own choice so their
intention is good the problem is it is
an impossible situation Mark Zuckerberg
Jack Dorsey all of it impossible for
them to solve this problem I have a tip
what as an informed reader and citizen
of this country you shouldn't just be
relying on a what politicians say or be
what you read in the news what you
should be doing is looking at what you
know is reported in the news and trying
to find the original source and read
that instead and decide for your own
self but you're using common sense and
rationality in a world that's irrational
and so what
ends up happening as people are lazy and
whatever is presented to them on social
media ends up being what they consume so
my whole thing with this is if you are
going to implement any sort of
arbitration of truth by the platform's
you absolutely have to apply to
mainstream media companies and that is
the fastest way to get them to start
saying we shouldn't have this because
the first time the New York Times has
labeled fake news or the Washington Post
or BuzzFeed or Business Insider or
whoever they're all gonna be freaking
out and so if you think that this is
like some conspiracy theory stuff I'll
walk you through something that would
have been interesting if this had been
in place earlier when the CDC and the
World Health Organization were saying
don't wear masks and if the New York
Times had written an article that said
you should wear a mask it would have
required that Twitter says this is fake
news we don't want to live in this world
this is not a world to go down this is a
censorship driven world that is not good
I actually don't think there's anything
wrong with Twitter saying here is
information that would support another
argument make your own decision okay so
again with the masks what why is Twitter
where are they gonna get the information
from and is Twitter gonna be willing to
go against the CDC or is Twitter gonna
say no we're only going online like
YouTube has YouTube has said if you go
against the world health organization we
are going to take down your videos so
this this gets it like the biggest issue
here which is people don't trust anybody
who are we supposed to trust where are
we supposed to get our information what
is what is accurate
well again the virus and the Internet is
really the Internet did this more so
than the virus has exposed the Sham of
we know that people are lying right we
know that for sure that my favorite
video that I saw on the internet
recently was a guy who's it was
somewhere sunny I don't know if it was
Arizona Florida wherever he was and
there was people walking all up and down
the south it was packed
and the reporter had on a face mask and
they were basically doing a whole report
on how no one's wearing a face mask
right and it's so bad and basically
reversed you signaling saying everyone
should be wearing a face mask which
again is a fair position to take and the
reporter had a mask on which is great
and all of a sudden they panned the
camera over and they started picking on
some guy because he's filming them with
his phone
and they go look even this guy's not
wearing one and the guy goes neither is
your cameraman or the rest of your crew
and he literally starts filming all of
the rest of the crew that isn't wearing
a face mask the whole idea is it's kind
of like got it was Anderson Cooper a
couple years ago during a tornado or
like a hurricane wasn't it was some but
some reporter and he was standing he was
pretending like he was about to get
blown over and then you just see two
guys walking in sandals behind him like
absolutely fine okay all the addresses
it's all of the address and the point
ends up being that the platform
shouldn't have any say and what sure
what's not because many times the things
that are initially thought to be false
outlandish crazy controversial whatever
we live in 2020 they end up being more
and more likely to be true do your own
research don't trust us don't trust
anybody nobody's looking out for you
okay
what's going on the Instagram for
Instagram flourish may look out for you
so Instagram ads are coming to Instagram
IG TV with revenue sharing for
influencers so suddenly Instagram is
going to start splitting the revenue and
earns from ads with influencers who
create the content for the service I
might get on there put a little bikini
on and start you know doing a little
hula dance or something this is cool
yeah I feel like this is a very smart
move Adam Morrissey is the runs
Instagram now I worked with him at
Facebook he's fantastic I'm sure at
least 55% of the revenue from these ads
with the creator's because they're
realizing these creators will go
somewhere else right well think about it
if I'm on tick-tock right now how do I
make money I basically have to find
influencer deals where they like tell me
stuff right it's all very very hard for
the influencer instead if all I have to
do is basically like on YouTube just
upload videos that are they getting very
popular and the yours pay me it's a
no-brainer and I think that 55% is
pretty attractive yeah and then from
Facebook and Instagram standpoint now
they have a new ad surface they could
sell more ads and yeah only at 45% but
the whole idea is just incentivize
people to create as much contest
possible they'll make billions of
dollars I think it's smart too are you
gonna get on and try to be an Instagram
influencer I'm a
on my black shirt my Yankees hat and
just is thank you are you truly a
giant's hat no it's hanging and I'll be
like what's up what's up what's up who's
gonna win this year with the Yankees and
the Giants play each other trick
question they don't play each other one
of them is a sport that I don't know
what they play football baseball
baseball you know you don't know what
baseball is I need a football no I know
that how many people are on the field in
baseball God like eight close nine
alright what's going on with reopening
ok so this is really funny can I just
read you guys the the lead of the lead
meaning the beginning of this article
it's great
New York is getting lapped on restaurant
reopening 'z by a city that can't even
do pizza right they talk about Chicago
if you're from Chicago I'm so sorry I
deep dish it's inferior to Domino's true
New York Pizza Domino's are the best
pizza in New York fight me
so like do you want me to fight you
right now actually that's probably not
true scars Joe's pizza there's a whole
list of them ok so he just named Ubuntu
restaurant said his brother likes he
doesn't actually know what that means he
Dominic Chicago has released a 13 page
list of guidelines for how restaurants
can safely resume service during the
pandemic so this is ridiculous
tables will be placed at least 6 feet
apart or have a permanent barrier such
as Plexiglas installed between them
while parties at one table should be
capped at six people patrons must always
wear face coverings except of course
when eating while employees should cover
up in protective gear at all times
I mean can you imagine going to these
Plexiglas restaurants the government is
dumb that's what this comes down to
literally the local government is dumb
they really believe they're gonna put
Plexiglas between tables and people are
gonna wear face masks except for to move
it so they get stuff food in their face
then put the thing back come on and oh
by the way you're a restaurant you
already have thin margins we've mandated
you be shut down for last two and a half
months we've literally taken away your
livelihood but what you can reopen you
can only have 20
the people there one of the small
business owner said okay so they keep
telling us you need to be six feet away
from you know the server's from the
restaurant diners so what are we
supposed to do like throw the plate at
you yeah by the way this is all getting
into like what's politically correct now
there is zero zero evidence that
suggests putting up Plexiglas between
dinner tables at a restaurant prevents
the spread of the buyers some people may
think that's intuitive but there is no
evidence that that shows that I don't
know just I think I mean I think 2020 a
shot to hell here's what I want to know
what restaurants are the politicians
going to I want to see the politicians I
want to see photos of the politicians no
no I want to see them with their face
masks sitting down being served by
somebody in protective gear surrounded
by plexiglass forget about it how are
you gonna be in a narrow long bar
staying six feet apart from another
person that's like three people let me
tell you what's really going on the
Minnesota governor said hey nobody
should go travel to the lakes and stuff
for Memorial Day weekend because that
would cause potentially arise and spread
the virus and then it came out her
husband who doesn't live at the place
where all these people go in in
Minnesota had called and wanted to get
his boat from Michigan where the hell
whatever state it is it's just the same
thing over and over and over again
people say do what I say not what I do I
don't see any politicians go into these
restaurants and until the politicians
are willing to go in they should allow
people to do whatever they want we have
40 seconds left SpaceX launch are you
sad
I was real disappointed yes yeah but the
launch got canceled when I can't so got
moved to Saturday because of weather
there were 17 minutes away 17 minutes
away from launching people into space I
was more disappointed you know why cuz I
had a whole list of fun facts that no
people didn't get to hear Saturday
around one o'clock we're gonna
livestream the whole thing for a couple
of hours I'm gonna drag planet into it
pizza blood lights and rocket launches
Saturday a 1 p.m. on YouTube make sure
you're there ok what's going on the
dinosaur asteroid okay what's going on
the dinosaur ash okay so you know how
there was this fury because I don't know
if this is fact-checked a dinosaur
killing asteroid struck earth a
deadliest possible angle new research
suggests but if you tweet this they
might block you for fake news so
basically it's just really interesting
that this asteroid that wiped out the
dinosaurs hit Earth in a weird angle and
you know and just mess everything up I'm
just really confused why doesn't more of
this stuff happen like I feel like
there's so many things out in space why
haven't we gotten hit by an asteroid
like that well the asteroid itself
supposedly didn't actually kill any but
it killed the dinosaurs right well
instead what happened is the theories
that the asteroid hit it created all
this like sulfur and I forget well I
think it's a co2 or something I forget
all the details but basically it created
all of this stuff in the atmosphere that
atmosphere then blocked the Sun create
this super long I read the Internet of
course
well cow farts is a big co2 contributor
is probably one of the largest you can
put seaweed into the cow feed and it
drastically reduces their gas yeah I was
very close on so the whole idea is that
basically the dinosaurs didn't die from
the asteroid impact the dinosaurs died
from the ensuing winter because the Sun
was blocked by all of the carbon dioxide
and sulfur in the atmosphere and
therefore basically it froze the
dinosaurs to death that still does not
answer my question of what happens if an
asteroid like how have we been able to
go so long without something hitting us
cuz we humans we athletic we see them
coming you ever see is dodging they
can't get it you be dodging asteroids
well I don't earth does or listen have
you ever seen an asteroid
a shooting star no have you ever seen an
asteroid no how you know they're real oh
my god that's some question one hold on
so so let's let's say that they are real
which I believe they're real but let's
just say that they're real you ever read
the article with like Oh an asteroid uh
just missed us by seventeen thousand two
hundred and forty six months yes yeah
how they know that cuz they have
telescopes and they measure stuff they
didn't think Pluto was a planet until
like three weeks ago literally when I
was in high school they're like Pluto's
a planet they're like no it's not then
it is no oh it is no they got before
they said oh we can't we don't have any
photos of it or some [ __ ] now they got
like super clear photos of Pluto like oh
yeah that's a planet yep confirmed yeah
it's a little guy hanging out Mars on
the other hand is just really trying to
steal the spot so my point here is that
how long ago did they say this 66
million years ago is when they say this
happened right humans need to go find a
new hobby it's great that we're trying
to figure this out or a new home but but
if we think that we're gonna figure out
with a high degree of confidence what
happened on earth 66 million years ago
through an asteroid impact that created
a prolonged winter that killed millions
of dinosaurs I mean you look it's super
interesting I'm glad other people are
doing the work it's just I think that
there is a lot of people spinning their
wheels and if you were to talk to ten
different people on what theories they
believe led to the extinction of
dinosaurs you could get ten okay but you
have to understand your past to know how
to handle your future I don't disagree
but I don't think understanding the
exact angle of impact that the asteroid
had to create the death of dinosaurs is
going to in your example help us prevent
running into another asteroid like I
don't think that we can do anything to
stop the asteroids from actually hitting
Earth I think you can I think you're
gonna shoot them I think that's a sci-fi
thing I don't think that's real if
that's real somebody will leave it in
the comments I would love to learn about
that I'll do a whole podcast I know so
how else do you think they're like
keeping us out of harm's way what makes
you think that we have the weaponry
shoot outside the atmosphere we can
shoot rockets you put things in like the
International Space Station like
spaceship sure ulong's working on it or
has work on it there's no space lasers
yeah there's no way we can go to Mars
but we don't know how to shoot rocks
away from hitting well we didn't go to
Mars well I'm saying there's no way
we're like trying I said trying to go to
Mars yeah yeah we sent the Mars rover
which I do believe is real yes yeah so
do I do you think we went to the moon oh
my god I will kill you yeah guys that
was a threat on live television just so
we're all clear
fainting happens to mean there's the
evidence wait we went to the moon what
why do you believe that I can just see
the comments I'm just asking I believe
it because numerous people have gone
talks about their experiences I've seen
everything I've been to the moon I think
we actually went to the moon I just like
to say that sometimes it's questionable
cuz it really upsets her and so I'll
leave you guys with one great story we
were in Washington DC and we went to a
place called the news meal no Museum
museum whatever others call it's a news
museum that would be a smart thing to do
but said they called it this other word
and so they've had these sections like
one's all about terrorism and one's all
about this whatever yeah I loved it this
was an awesome place probably one of my
favorite museums that ever gone to and
one of the sections was about space and
so we were standing there and they were
playing the video of Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin all these guys walking around on
the moon or whatever and there was a lot
of people around a lot of people
surrounding us and they were a little
baffled a little bit older a little bit
stuffier you know kind of not the crew
that's probably watching lunch money
it's more though Walsh we trying to get
rich rather than the rest of us trying
to get our lunch money right and so I
couldn't help myself I said real loud
real obnoxiously I was looking at the
video and I said you're telling me that
they were streaming live in HD in 1960
and I can't get Sunday football the work
on my television come on this isn't real
we didn't go and I just start saying
obnoxious things just loud enough where
these stuffy people can hear but not
loud enough to actually draw attention
from like the security or anything and
polina immediately grabs my arm and
Yangtze yanked me out of there she was
and we're going to a different section
that was truly the worst and then we had
to talk about the and then he tweeted
like what did you tweet about me like
how come if we if what was it some guy
told me what time he said he said I
don't think we went cuz you can't see
the flag he was like how come if we went
to the moon how come we don't like go
back or whatever and somebody tweeted
and it was like man there's a lot of
places I went to once that I ain't never
alright guys that's it for the day lunch
money well while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right dinosaur asteroid
SpaceX launches unemployment Instagram
influencers pretty much lunch mines the
best place on the internet you won't get
this content anywhere else some of you
have been complaining that YouTube is
not sending you push notifications when
we post the videos so we created an
email list if you want to get at it
clean it up created it because she's
smart I'm not if you want to get added
just go into the comments we'll pin it
there you can sign up and every day
we'll just send you an email with the
latest episode and include the links to
the stories you can go read and do your
own research that's it see you tomorrow
Friday tomorrow Rebecca Black Friday
Friday see you
bang-bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina they've got 3 products
they can give you a US dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated
eight point six percent it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block bye subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy playing in the comment
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends